ich würde dann aber trotzdem gerne mal
wissen welche noch die hässlichsten
Städte Deutschlands sind nach meiner
Heimatstadt Gelsenkirchen Gelsenkirchen
ist das nicht in der Nähe von Schalke
also Gelsenkirchen kann ich voll
verstehen da also wer da wohnt hat eh
komplett verloren hat schon so manch
einer gefragt und es stimmt wenn man an
die Stadt im Ruhrgebiet denkt denkt man
natürlich zu allererst an den Fußball
das einzige was da schönes auch wenn ich
Dortmund Fan bin ist der Fußballverein
also das ist eine geile Sache aber sonst
Gelsenkirchen kannst du komplett
vergessen Verein aus dem Stadtteil
Schalke und an seine top moderne Arena
der Rest der Stadt ist allerdings Land
Scheiße ganz großer Quatsch sieht oben
wenn ihr da wohnt